hey everyone welcome to the heavy
spoilers show I'm your host definition
and with Jumanji the next level upping
its game and leaving a huge teaser for a
sequel it's time to break down exactly
what happens at the end of the film and
what it means for the future throughout
this video which is going to be going
through the movie discussing what
happens in the post-credits scene and
the implications that it has for next
time so whether you didn't stick around
to watch it or you just have questions
about the ending then this is the video
for you now obviously there's gonna be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to watch the episode yet
and don't want to know what happens then
I highly recommend that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into our breakdown of
Jumanji the next level post-credit scene
okay so Jumanji the next level ends at
the diner after the events of the movie
that saw Eddie played by Danny DeVito
and his ex bestfriend Milo played by
Danny Glover fallout after they had a
dispute over selling it throughout the
movie the two kind of bicker back and
forth but eventually they ended up
becoming friends again after the events
of the game made them put their
differences aside
Milo decided to remain behind in Jumanji
to protect it after he revealed that he
was dying while steady returned to the
real world with the adventure over
Spencer and Eddie go back to the diner
which is now owned by Nora Shepard
played by none other than baby Newerth
who you may remember was actually the
auntie of the two kids from the first
film and this is an awesome little cameo
for fans of the 1995 original she says
that as the prior manager recently quit
she's looking for someone to fill the
position and channeling the smouldering
intensity of the videogame avatar
dr. smolder brave stone Danny manages to
get the job the movie ends with a group
all back together going for the meal
that they were supposed to early on and
they celebrate all that they've been
through together which is when we cut
two credits now from here we jump to the
mid-credits scene and we see the
concurrent events at Spencer's house
where a mechanic has finally arrived to
fix the central heating that Eddie
complained about earlier in the Moon
Spencer's mom takes the mechanic played
by lamorne Morris down the stairs to
start work which is when they spot the
Jumanji videogame console
the latter says he's a big gamer and
evidently he couldn't keep his hands off
it even with a warning because we then
cut to the diner and see a herd of
ostriches running past I think going
forward the third film is gonna echo the
events of the first movie with the game
pretty much leaking into the real world
and it taking place there rather than
inside the digital one fans of the first
gym and you will have course fall in
love with this as watching the kids
tackle all of the dangers of the game in
the real world was a big selling point
of that movie when discussing this Haram
Garcia told cinema blend the first
Jumanji the very first one with Robin
Williams is so beloved it was beloved to
us and what was important to us when we
went and made welcome to the jungle was
that we didn't want to remake Jumanji
that was never the goal because you want
to let such a beloved film like that
that means so much to so many people
stand on its own we wanted to build upon
it we wanted to expand that universe so
that's why we always acknowledge that
movie that world existed what happened
there you know you feel elements of it
even in this movie so for us the idea of
expanding the Jumanji universe and the
idea of there being different versions
of the game there's different ways the
game can challenge you the bigger we can
make the universe the more opportunities
and challenges we can give to our heroes
you've met some of the avatars you meet
new avatars in this movie and when you
start to get into that space where we're
now creating a Jumanji universe every
time you beat one version of the game
there's a new one so it does look like
they love the first film and they're now
looking to build the universe where the
two can come together now I kind of have
a theory that we may even see the
characters of the game come into the
real world and it would be awesome to
see the game cast of characters mixing
with the real ones I don't know how
they'll do it as they're mainly avatars
but if Spencer's mum is inhabiting one
as well as the mechanic then it could
allow for some awesome back-and-forth
Milo will still likely protect the game
from the inside whilst the others help
to lock down the real world and it
leaves the future open to a lot of
possibilities
could also travel back into the game to
lock everything off which yet that could
lead to an awesome duality in the movie
either way with the big box office and
the film doing well critically it looks
like we're gonna be getting a sequel
pretty soon so keep your eyes peeled for
updates as they drop now obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on the film
and what you took from the ending make
sure you comment below and let me know
and if you enjoyed this video then
please give it a thumbs up and if you
want to watch more Jumanji stuff that
make sure you head over to a partner
channel BAM Alam
where we interviewed the rock and Kevin
Hart if you want to come chat to me
after the video then make sure you
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey will head over to my discord
server which be linked in the
description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else and that's the best
place to be it's free to join and we
have an awesome community so hope they
see you over there very soon we're also
giving away a free copy of Joker which
is one of our favorite movies of last
year and all you have to do to be in
with the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts and
jumanji the next level in the comments
section below the winners gonna be
chosen on the 15th of January and the
set will be shipped out from the in Toba
gets the prize so best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who were mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you